so the Cleveland Clinic has made history  with the for the first time in North  America a woman gave birth after  receiving a uterus transplant from a  deceased donor now the reason this is  significant is first of all one in 5,000  women cannot have children because of a  uterine problem typically to fix that  problem they have to do really complex  surgery on living women take a uterus  from one woman what is in another one  now for the first time in North America  they've done it with a person yeah  it opens windows for all these women who  suffer from this issue and it reminds me  of what Jeff Goldblum said in Jurassic  Park nature will find a way well maybe  not nature the doctor your guide your  clinic medicine yeah we'll find a way so  it's it's a great encouraging news it is  really kind up